bonsoir monsieur le Président une
dernière question si vous le permettez
pour clore la séquence de de politique
intérieure vous avez implicitement
évoqué le rôle des femmes dans le cadre
du réarmement démographique que vous
appelez de vos vœux depuis 2017
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
fait partie euh des grandes cause de
votre quinquena c'est un axe fort de
votre politique d'ailleurs la parité est
atteinte dans le gouvernement euh de
votre premier ministre mais pourquoi n'y
a-t-il aucune femme à la tête d'un d'un
ministère régalien 2ème question la
révolution Mitou a permis d'aider à une
prise de conscience contre les attitudes
prédatrices de certains hommes une
révolution initiée par les médias qui
sont fait ni pour se substituer à la
justice mais pour dénoncer des des
agissements
répréhensibles ces attitudes odieuses
comme celle mise à jour par les images
de nos confrères de complément d'enquête
sur Gérard de pardieu est-ce que vous
comprenez monsieur le Président les mois
provoqués par vos propos sur la fierté
que vous inspire une telle personnalité
est-ce que la lutte contre les violences
sexuelles et sexistes reste une priorité
de votre mandat merci beaucoup merci de
m'offrir là
l'opportunité de clarifier ce sujet
essentiel bon d'abord le gouvernement
est paritaire vous l'avez dit et il sera
complété ensuite et continuera d'être
paritaire et il y a eu depuis le début
de mes responsabilité des moments où il
y avait plus de femmes qui étaient dans
le carré régalien d'autres moment où
c'était à des fonctions qui sont clés
quand j'ai martelé
que la santé l'école et l'enseignement
supérieur étaient au cœur de mes
priorités comme politique
publique je constate que vous avez une
femme ministre de la Santé du travail et
des solidarité une femme ministre de
l'éducation nationale et des Jio une
femme ministre de l'Enseignement
supérieur et de la Recherche voilà et
c'est aussi une forme de nouveau
régalien je
l'assume donc n'y voyez pas là malice ou
retrait bien au contraire il y a eu
beaucoup de polémiqu ces dernières
semaines ça ne m'a pas échappé je me
permettrai toutefois de
dire que je me souvient d'octobre
2016 c'était la conclusion de ce qu'on
avait appelé la grande marche j'étais
alors pas encore candidat simplement
ministre
démissionnaire c'était le début d'une
longue série de commentaires politiques
où l'on me disait que je n'avais pas de
programme ça a duré très
longtemps et faisant le contre-rendu de
cette grande marche je disais la
première préoccupation ce sont les
violences faites aux femmes en
particulier dans les transports j'ai pas
attendu Mitou j'ai eu le regard
sceptique de beaucoup de gens et
beaucoup de commentateurs
aujourd'hui disant c'est vraiment un
drôle lui c'est ça sa
priorité les archives sont là pour le
montrer allez aussi les chercher cl donc
moi j'assume de pas avoir t du Mitou
pour dire l'égalité femmes hommes et les
violences faites aux femmes c'est un
problème inadmissible et parfois un
continent caché et j'assume en effet
depuis 6 ans et demi d'avoir agi avec
beaucoup de force et je vais vous dire
je n'ai aucun regret d'avoir défendu la
présomption d'innocence pour une
personnalité publique un artiste en
l'espèce comme je l'ai fait pour des
responsables politiques si j'ai un
regret à ce moment-là c'est de ne pas
avoir assez dit combien la parole des
femmes qui sont victimes de ces
violences est importante et combien ce
combat est essentiel pour moi et nous
continu l'action mais on a agi on a
multiplié comme jamais les crédits aux
associations qui qui se développent sur
le terrain on a multiplié par 2 et demi
les ordonnances de protection on a
développé plus de 1000 bracelets qui
sont offerts et qui protègent chaque
jour des femmes on a facilité le moyen
de dénoncer les conjoints ou mari
violent on a formé tous nos policiers
nos gendarmes qui étaient en école au
total 140000 d'entre eux sont formés
pour prendre les plaintes ce qui était
pas pas du tout le cas avant on a
développé ces téléphones grave danger
qui sont si importants les places
d'hébergement sont passé de 5000 à 10000
de 5000 à 10000 le 391 si important pour
toutes les femmes qui sont victimes de
ces violences a eu des moyens accrus
comme jamais et passé 7 jours sur 7 et
24 heur sur 24 et encore et encore je
pourrais
continuer depuis le premier jour et même
avant comme je le rappelais le sujet des
violences faites aux femmes est une
priorité nous continuerons de nous
battre contre ce phénomène de société il
y a eu des tas de milieux où en effet
l'omerta a prévalu et je me félicite que
la parole se libère et je souhaite
qu'elle puisse se libérer au maximum
mais je pense que notre rôle c'est de
permettre son cadre c'est que la justice
puisse faire son travail c'est qu'on
protège les femmes qui sont menacées
mais que là aussi on ne le fasse pas en
oubliant les principes constitutionnels
qui sont les nôtres dans la présomption
d'innocence
[Musique]